hello and welcome to swipe coming up
working nine to five high technology is
changing life in the office mama do the
hump rizzle kicks shores their shooting
skills on the new call of duty virtual
currency moving into the real world with
the world's first Bitcoin ATM and our me
hearties we are battling pirates and
helping a certain Hedgehog find his way
in this week's games of you take a look
inside any office these days and you'll
find practically every business is
dependent on technology from our desktop
computers to video conference calls pull
the plug and we'd be lost but is it
making us more productive or creating
more distractions skies Katie Spencer
has been taking a look keeping up with
the technology we use at work can be a
full-time job in itself increased
connectivity has transformed the average
workplace according to a new study since
the 70s office productivity has
increased by eighty-four percent hardly
surprising given how the tools around us
have changed with today's cloud
computing we can work anywhere at any
time so where do we draw the line you're
gonna be able to get more productivity
from each individual within the hours
that they're they're actually working so
it's a personal choice on where the
barrier is between office and the home
life mobile phones and emails are the
biggest reason behind the boost between
now and 2020 productivity is expected to
go up by another twenty two percent
could this mean email overload it may
look like an ordinary office but Yammer
a social network run by Microsoft is
looking at new ways for us to
communicate at work many people for
example will feel change to their email
they feel that you know I've got my
inbox is full all the time and I must
empty it when in reality that's just the
process of work it's not work itself
some critics argue that the pressure to
constantly stay connected is in fact
making us less effective at work taking
away from the time we need to
stop and think all you're doing if
you're stuck in that technology carousel
of constant distraction constant
interruption is you're always reacting
you're never reflecting testing out new
ideas is equally important at Google I'm
about to dial in to hang out and I'm
going to be meeting with my colleague my
PR colleague in France at its London
office Google Hangouts has become
standard an alternative to sending
endless emails allowing employees
wherever they are in the world to work
together on the same document a team
which might take in hours or even days
in the past can now take minutes and you
can collaborate across regions and
countries and borders crazily using
social media in more of a business
context could help save us time in the
future rather than just updates about
you know your personal life why not
updates about the latest product launch
or the latest bit of information but
doing that in a kind of flexible way so
you don't feel that you have to review
every single email you read staying in
touch with the office may be easier than
ever but knowing when to switch off is
becoming even harder still Katie Spencer
Sky News you're watching swipe coming up
virtual currency moving into the real
world with the world's first Bitcoin ATM
but first get ready to lock in the Lord
if you're a fan of first-person shooters
no doubts you've been eagerly awaiting
this moment the big release of call of
duty ghosts the pressure is on for it to
do big things especially off the back of
the massive success that was grand theft
auto 5 but does it live up to the hype
well before the big November fifth
launch we caught up with our celeb mates
rizzle kicks the boys were asked to lead
us squads in a special pre-launch
tournament and they let us tag along for
a top-secret test of the game when we
get into the tour bus we can I go right
he wants to get shot I have like
problems just have compared to very
compressed i get in fact i had to kind
of take a backseat with this in kind
joy what I winner the things man I'll
beat him at FIFA yeah but call the
jury's get your guilt you'll be bad in
your quiet mmm just with a little guy
it'll play and I'm already pretty
addicting i think i think as long as you
know went us maybe stop yeah it's like
one of the best games you'll play it's
just that whole it's a content they
school that cranked when you kill
someone you get like a powerup it's
hardcore yeah i think it's the nature of
when you have to advance anything at fun
of maybe goes into different areas you
it hasn't explored previously there's a
launch going on and there's going to be
lucky there's maybe like a big match
with with us reps 3 2 because and one of
the captain and daniel sturridge
basically are our tactics are just to be
the best at smack talk they can all give
it that yeah but like when it comes
around with a pad that means when it
gets real yeah we're going to be needs
to think of more things like that yeah
yeah well when we come across you a call
of duty anything you'll be calling your
mom my other tactical side of the smack
talk is to come dressed in an animal
onesie dangerous you're watching swype
coming up batten down the hatches splice
the Mainbrace and pass me a bottle of
rum honestly i do not write this stuff
will be checking out the Golden Age of
piracy in this week's games with you but
first your end up of anything you might
have missed over the last few days
facebook co-founder mark zuckerberg is
insisting the company's strong quarterly
results show that facebook is prepared
for the next phase almost all of the key
numbers have exceeded analyst
expectations revenue is up sixty percent
to 2.0 two billion dollars however it's
not all rosy the company conceded that
daily activity amongst teens has
declined which explains the considerable
drop in share price meanwhile apples
fourth-quarter earnings have fallen nine
percent as more people opt for the
company's lower-priced iPhones and iPads
it's the third consecutive quarter that
its earnings have dropped compared with
the previous year the tech giant said it
sought 33.8 million iphones and 14.1
million iPads between july
each year bafta announces its
breakthrough Brett's list for 2013 17
people were picked out from the
entertainment won't one of those was
Sofia George the games designer in
residence at the Victoria and Albert
Museum at the moment I'm working on a
game based on a William Morris textile
pattern called strawberry thief and it's
in really early development at the
moment I'm hoping that you can control
the birds and steal the strawberries as
they come down Ronald's fast cash
machine for buying and selling the
online currency Bitcoin has been
installed at a coffee shop in Canada the
kiosk has a hand scanner and uses facial
recognition to verify customers
identities before they PN or take out
cash from their digital wallet so you've
just brought you a lovely new laptop
home wrapped up in the packaging but
what's that smell cat urine downs had to
investigate after a number of new users
complained they got slightly more than
they bargained for with their latitude
6430u ultrabooks engineer's insist what
was making the smell wasn't hazardous
and simply a problem with the
manufacturing process which is now being
changed so it can't happen anymore well
I don't know about you but I gets quite
worked up about being stuck in traffic
so how about the ultimate escape Stefan
Klein an engineer from Ostia is my new
heel this is the it'll will be all 2.5 a
flying car admittedly it's not entirely
clear from the video how long you could
stay up in the air for not to mention
how it it ever be practical on the roads
but nonetheless I want one sign me up
fancy an adventure well in this week's
games review we've got the lot battles
with pirates there a ton of a familiar
fast friend and a comic come to life our
gaming girl Jane Douglas has been taking
us through some of her favorite new
releases
All Hands half-bloods thousands before
Black Flag you play as Edward Kenway who
is pirate captain in the Caribbean in
the Golden Age of piracy so the 18th
century he gets caught up in this
ancient conflict between the Templars
who are the bad guys in the assassins or
the good guys and so that's what makes
it an assassin's creed game but more
importantly it's just a game about
having a really brilliant time being a
pirate in this big beautiful open
seamless world where you've basically
got total freedom of the map to do all
these authentically priority things of
which there are a ton to be getting on
with my man plays the fool then it's
only fools you'll persuade it doesn't
really fine job of keeping you invested
in this wealth of activities with a
really slow burning but really engaging
storyline and likeable roguish pirate
character who is edward kenway and it's
much more interested in fact it's only
interested in the real historical side
of piracy and real historical pirates so
you'll meet Blackbeard and you'll meet
Calico Jack for instance but you won't
get any of the Pirates of the Caribbean
pirate Hollywood cliché nonsense which
is is kind of refreshing and also it
strikes me that and it's actually really
hard to come by a good pirate game when
pirates are such an ideal matter to make
video games about
sonic lost world is the latest in the
Sonic the Hedgehog series of games it is
out now for the Nintendo Wii U and also
as a version for the Nintendo 3ds so
it's business as usual for Sonic because
you're playing as Sonic and you're
rescuing cute little animals from the
evil dr. Eggman and you're doing that by
running really fast jumping collecting
rings bopping monsters who then turn it
rings so the game is a mixture of 2d and
3d levels the 2d ovals are of the kind
that Sonic fans will remember from
sonics heyday in the early 90s so flat
colorful backdrops and then there are
different kinds of three-dimensional
environments some of which will possibly
remind mario nintendo fans of the the
spherical worlds in the mario galaxy
games which is kind of what sonic lost
world is going after so on it's got a
bit of a wobbly track record a bit of a
checkered past when it comes to
attempting 3d games and the 3d is the
environments are for the most part
successful they look bright and colorful
and they're fun and a little bit
nostalgic which I think goes down well
for Sonic as a storied game character
where it falls down a bit is with
overloading the gameplay with a gimmicky
power-ups which kind of bog it down and
take away from the pure speed which i
think is is so important for a sonic
game the wolf among us is a game about
the cast of fairytale characters who've
been exiled from their homeland and have
started a community in real-world New
York in a very unfair retail like
setting the game is based on a set of
quite dark adults comic books called
fables and similarly the game is a dark
adult story kind of noir II styled it's
a very stylish-looking game it's kind of
a storybook adventure
it takes a point-and-click adventure
because you go around set crime scene
collecting clues and having
conversations with our characters and
the the crucial thing about this about
this game about the wolf among us is
that the decisions you may the things
you do and the things you say to other
characters affect how the story unfolds
and how the other characters react to
you how they feel about you so it
becomes real interactive story and the
story is it's very cleverly written it's
very engaging and the characters are
very nicely brought over from the comic
book series which I'm a big fan of
something's going on Big B did one of us
do this
well that's a lot for this week remember
you can catch up with the breaking tech
stories all week on Sky News for iPad or
smartphone apps and scary news.com you
see you next time